اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من جنوب لبنان اهلا
بكم اجمالي عدد الشهداء تجاوز
4700 ونسبه الذين نزحوا عن منازلهم قصرا
بلغت نحو 70% مع استمرار الغارات
الاسرائيليه على القطاع من جهتها ردت
المقاومه برشقات صاروخيه على غلاف غزه
وشرقي عسقلان كما سمع دوي انفجارات في تل
ابيب وغربي
القدس وك لات امميه تطالب بوقف فوري
لاطلاق النار ودخول غير محدود المساعدات
الى القطاع محذره من كارثه انسانيه اثر
نفاد الوقود في غضون ثلاثه ايام في حين
قال الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني ان 2 مستشفى
مهدده بالقصف في اي لحظه جراء اوامر
الاخلاء في الضفه الغربيه استشهد خمسه
فلسطينيين جراء قصف الاحتلال مسجدا في
جنين واندلاع مواجهات في ط باص وقبطيه
وشرق نابلس ليرتفع اجمالي عدد الشهداء في
الضفه الى 90 منذ بدء الحرب على
غزه على الجبهه الشماليه اسرائيل تقصف
مزارع شبعه وبلدات في جنوب لبنان وتقرر
اخلاء مزيد من البلدات وحزب الله يستهدف
مواقع اسرائيليه في حين توعد نتنياهو
لبنان بدمار لا يمكن تخيله اذا انضم حزب
الله للمواجهه الى اللقاء
ه